Discovery Channel's Deadliest Catch depicts
the real-life risks of Alaskan crab fishing.
However, the show doesn't quite catch everything.
Let's dock the Sea Star, Time Bandit, and
all other boats to get a closer look at Deadliest
Catch.
ELLIOTT NEESE'S REHAB STAY
During season 11 of Deadliest Catch, then
Captain Elliott Neese abruptly handed over
the helm of the Saga to first mate Jeff Folk
and left his ship—leaving viewers wondering
why he went AWOL.
After rumors swirled in tabloids about his
addiction problems, Neese himself tweeted
in May 2015 that he'd entered a 60-day program
at Passages Malibu for an undisclosed program.
He wrote that he'd "had issues," but after
his stay at Passages, had "a new outlook on
things now."
NEESE'S RESTRAINING ORDER
It seems Elliott Neese is a magnet for trouble.
Back in 2012, he got himself slapped with
a restraining order, according to documents
cited by Entertainment Weekly.
It seems he'd been harassing his baby mamma
Valerie Gunderson for the better part of a
month, maybe more.
In her petition, Gunderson said she feared
for her personal safety "in the event that
Elliott ‘snaps’ so to speak."
She also claimed that during one incident
in 2010, Neese got so angry that he destroyed
her television—and then started burning
her clothes in the fireplace.
It seems that for Gunderson, snagging Neese's
heart was a pretty deadly catch in and of
itself.
FREDDY MAUGATAI: BATHROOM BRAWLER
Apparently, Feleti "Freddy" Maugatai has some
mixed-martial arts ambitions.
According to a criminal complaint obtained
by TMZ, Maugatai got involved in a fight against
a husband and wife team in the bathroom of
the Grand Aleutian Hotel back in December
2011.
Maugatai claims he was defending himself when
he put the husband in a headlock and shoved
the guy's wife.
Police arrested him, despite his story.
He was later fired from his ship for an unrelated
incident, but maybe he should look into bringing
his untapped fighting prowess to the octagon.
Each of his fights could be called "Deadliest
Match!"
Don't deny it: you'd watch it.
JAKE HARRIS: DRUNK DRIVER
Jake Harris, son of the late Captain Phil
Harris, seems to have made a smooth transition
from crab fisherman to reality star.
Back in 2010, Jake was arrested for a hit
and run, driving under the influence, and
driving with a suspended license after crashing
his BMW in Seattle, according to People Magazine.
Supposedly, Jake had a tough time dealing
with his father's death.
But while that may explain his actions, it
certainly didn't justify them.
Plus, it's not the best way to honor his father's
legacy.
Neither was his other indiscretion…
JAKE HARRIS' DRUG STRUGGLES
In November 2010, TMZ reported that Captain
Derek Ray, of the Cornelia Marie, called police
to the boat because he suspected Jake Harris
was abusing drugs while at sea.
Police discovered "paraphernalia," but it
wasn't enough to charge Jake with any crime.
A few years later, Jake was noticeably absent
from Deadliest Catch's 2013 promos.
According to his brother Josh, via Huffington
Post, Jake was "lost in drugs," obviously
still reeling from his father's death.
"Jake’s gotta take care of his own stuff
right now.
Deal with his demons," said Josh.
Fortunately, as of August 2015, Jake was clean
and captaining his father's old boat.
JOSHUA TEL WARNER: BANK ROBBER
Despite the crimes committed by other Deadliest
Catchers, Joshua Tel Warner might be the biggest
criminal of them all.
According to CBS News, Warner was wanted for
a series of bank robberies that took place
in Oregon from 2007 to 2009.
So what did Warner do to lay low?
He appeared on television.
Oregon law enforcement officials recognized
Warner during a 2010 episode of Deadliest
Catch and immediately issued a warrant for
his arrest.
Warner plead guilty to reduce his prison sentence
from 30 years to nine and a half years.
Side note for any aspiring bank robbers: the
only time you should appear on TV is on Cops.
DRUG TRAFFICKING PRODUCERS
Even the people behind-the-scenes on Deadliest
Catch are magnets for trouble.
Production manager Matthew Schneider was charged
in April 2010 for selling and using cocaine,
according to The Associated Press.
Schneider's illicit activities were discovered
after he allegedly sold about $300 worth of
the stuff to an undercover officer—and used
some of it in front of the officer as well.
Oops!
He also revealed that some other show employees
were involved in a drug-trafficking affair,
which resulted in the arrests of 18 people.
HILLSTRAND BROTHERS ABANDON SHIP
The best thing to happen to a breakout character
on a hit show is scoring a spin-off—unless
they're the Hillstrand brothers.
In 2010, Discovery offered Jonathan and Andy
their own show, to be called Hillstranded.
Discovery even started filming footage for
it.
However, when the time came to record voiceovers
and polish everything up, the brothers were
nowhere to be found, according to E! Online.
This didn't sit well with Discovery, who slapped
them with a $3 million lawsuit.
The Hillstrands retaliated by leaving Deadliest
Catch altogether, taking fan-favorite Captain
Sig Hansen with them.
They all eventually made up, but the Hillstrands'
trouble didn't end there…
FIREWORKS FOLLIES
The Hillstrand brothers may need to hand over
some money to crew member David "Beaver" Zielinski,
according to Seattle PI.
In 2013, the Hillstrands wanted to celebrate
a Seattle Seahawks victory by shooting off
some fireworks—because, yeah, shooting off
fireworks on a boat is a good idea.
Under captain's orders, Zielinski lit off
a mortar like a foolishly obedient deckhand.
The firework, which was made by the Hillstrands,
exploded while he held it, shattering the
bones in his hand and forearm.
Beaver filed his suit in 2015, seeking an
undisclosed amount.
Looks like choppy waters ahead for the Hillstrands
after all...
ALASKA DISLIKES THE SHOW
While viewers still love Deadliest Catch,
Alaska had its fill of the show, according
to Alaska Dispatch News.
To summarize the complex issue, the boats
featured on the show are making things difficult
for the rest of the northern crabbing fleet
to earn a living.
It seems that the Discovery Channel's funding
of fishing expeditions, in whole or part,
has affected the crews not participating in
the show.
That's made it difficult for them to keep
up.
In some cases, those crews end up earning
minimum wage, and crabbing "is far too dangerous"
for such miniscule pay.
On the other hand, it does afford Discovery
Channel the opportunity to create a show about
former fisherman now living on skid row.
BEHIND THE SCENES FAKERY?
Like most reality shows, Deadliest Catch is
guilty of dressing up the events that happen
in real life.
In their case, producers made it appear as
though one of the ships was in danger of being
sunk by huge waves during a storm, which is
an honest hazard of crab fishing.
However, the episode in which this was dramatized
was filmed in September 2008, while the waves
themselves were filmed a month later, according
to The Hollywood Reporter.
Unsurprisingly, the Discovery Channel denies
any trickery.
Caught red-handed?
Or perhaps red-clawed?
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to see more
videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to tell us what surprised
you the most about The Deadliest Catch crew...